i stand before you today to fulfill one
of my highest and most important duties
under the united states constitution
the nomination of a supreme court
justice
this is my third such nomination
after justice gorsuch and justice
kavanaugh
and it is a very proud moment indeed
over the past week our nation has
mourned the loss
of a true american legend
justice ruth bader ginsburg was a legal
giant
and a pioneer for women her
extraordinary life and legacy will
inspire americans for
generations to come now we gather in the
rose garden
to continue our never ending task
of ensuring equal justice and preserving
the impartial rule of law
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
she is a woman of unparalleled
achievement
towering intellect sterling credentials
and unyielding loyalty to the
constitution
judge amy coney barrett
we're also joined by amy's husband jesse
thank you jesse very much and their
seven beautiful children
congratulations to you all very special
day
with us as well our the first lady thank
you first lady along with
vice president mike pence and his
amazing wife karen thank you very much
[Music]
judge barrett is a graduate of rhodes
college and
the university of notre dame law school
at notre dame she earned a full academic
scholarship
served as the executive editor of the
law review
graduated first in her class and
received the law schools award for the
best record of
scholarship and achievement upon
graduation she became a clerk
for judge lawrence silberman on the
u.s court of appeals for the district of
columbia
amy then received one of the highest
honors a young
lawyer could have serving as a clerk on
the supreme court for
justice antonin scalia
a highly
a very highly respected law professor
at notre dame wrote to justice scalia
with a one sentence recommendation
amy coney is the best student i
ever had that's pretty good
justice scalia hired her shortly
thereafter and we are honored to have
his wonderful wife maureen where is
maureen
maureen scalia with us today
thank you
and our great secretary of labor thank
you very much
thank you mr secretary
very good genes in that family i will
say very good genes
before joining the bench judge barrett
spent 15 years as a professor at the
university of notre dame law school
she was renowned for her scholarship
celebrated by her colleagues and beloved
by her students
three times she was selected at notre
dame
distinguished professor of the year when
i nominated judge barrett to serve on
the u.s court of appeals for the seventh
circuit
in 2017 every law clerk
from her time at the supreme court
endorsed her
and endorsed her nomination writing
quote we are democrats republicans and
independents
yet we right to support the nomination
of professor barrett
to be a circuit judge professor barrett
is a woman
of remarkable intellect and character
she is eminently qualified for the job
and i can tell you i did that too i
looked and i studied and
you are very eminently qualified for
this job you are going to be fantastic
thank you
really fantastic
the entire notre dame law facility
and faculty everybody everybody at that
school also
we got so many letters also wrote
letters of support
of amy's nomination to the seventh
circuit
they wrote in effect despite our
differences we unanimously agree
that our constitutional system depends
upon an independent judiciary staffed by
talented people
devoted to the fair and impartial
administration of the rule of law and we
unanimously agree
that amy is such a person
for the last three years judge barrett
has served with immense distinction
on the federal bench amy is more than a
stellar scholar and judge she's
also a profoundly devoted mother
her family is a core part of who amy is
she opened her home and her heart
and adopted two beautiful children from
haiti her incredible bond with her
youngest child a son with down syndrome
is a true inspiration if confirmed
justice barrett
will make history as the first mother of
school-aged
children ever to serve on the u.s
supreme court
that's good
to her children emma vivian tess
john peter liam julian and benjamin
thank you for sharing your incredible
mom
with our country thank you very much
amy coney barrett will decide cases
based on the text of the constitution
as written as amy has said
being a judge takes courage you are not
there to decide cases
as you may prefer you are there to do
your duty
and to follow the law wherever
it may take you that is exactly what
judge barrett will do
on the u.s supreme court i want to thank
the members of the senate we have so
many of them here today thank you very
much i see you in the audience and
you're so proud
but i want to thank you for your
commitment and to providing a fair and
timely hearing i know it will be that
judge barrett was confirmed to the
circuit court three years ago by a
bipartisan vote
her qualifications are unsurpassed
unsurpassed and her
record is beyond reproach this should be
a
straightforward and prompt confirmation
should be very easy good luck it's going
to be very
quick i'm sure it'll be extremely
non-controversial
we said that the last time didn't we
well thank you all very much and thank
you for being here that's really great
thank you
thank you i further urge all members of
the other side of the aisle to provide
judge barrett with the respectful and
dignified hearing
that she deserves and frankly that our
country deserves
i urge lawmakers and members of the
media to refrain from personal or
partisan attacks and
the stakes for our country are
incredibly
high rulings that the supreme court will
issue
in the coming years will decide the
survival of our second amendment
our religious liberty our public safety
and so much more
to maintain security liberty and
prosperity we must preserve our
priceless heritage of
a nation of laws and there is no one
better
to do that than amy coney
barrett law and order is the foundation
of the american
system of justice no matter the issue no
matter the case before her
i am supremely confident that judge
barrett
will issue rulings based solely upon a
fair reading of the law
she will defend the sacred principle of
equal justice for citizens of every race
color
religion and creed congratulations again
to judge barrett
i know that you will make our country
very
very proud please amy
say a few words thank you very much
congratulations
thank you
thank you very much mr president
i am deeply honored by the confidence
that you have placed in me
and i am so grateful to you and the
first lady
to the vice president and the second
lady and to so many others here
for your kindness on this rather
overwhelming occasion
i fully understand that this is a
momentous decision
for a president and if the senate does
me the honor of confirming me
i pledge to discharge the
responsibilities of this job to the very
best of my ability
i love the united states and i love the
united states constitution
i am truly
i am truly humbled by the prospect of
serving on the supreme court
should i be confirmed i will be mindful
of who came before me
the flag of the united states is still
flying at half-staff
in memory of justice ruth bader ginsburg
to mark the end of a great american life
justice ginsburg began her career at a
time
when women were not welcome in the legal
profession
but she not only broke glass ceilings
she smashed them
for that she has won the admiration of
women
across the country and indeed all over
the world
she was a woman of enormous talent and
consequence
and her life of public service serves as
an example to us all
particularly poignant to me was her long
and deep friendship with justice antonin
scalia my own mentor
justices galia and ginsburg disagreed
fiercely in print without rancor in
person
their ability to maintain a warm and
rich
friendship despite their differences
even inspired an opera
these two great americans demonstrated
that
arguments even about matters of great
consequence
need not destroy affection
in both my personal and professional
relationships
i strive to meet that standard
i was lucky enough to clerk for justice
scalia
and given his incalculable influence on
my life
i am very moved to have members of the
scalia family here today
including his dear wife maureen i
clerked for justice scalia
more than 20 years ago but the lessons i
learned
still resonate his judicial philosophy
is mine too a judge must apply the law
as written judges are not policy makers
and they must be resolute and setting
aside any policy views they might hold
the president has asked me to become the
ninth justice
and as it happens i'm used to being in a
group of nine
my family
our family includes me my husband jesse
emma vivian tess gent peter
liam juliet and benjamin
vivian and john peter as the president
said were born in haiti and they came to
us
five years apart when they were very
young and the most revealing fact about
benjamin
our youngest is that his brothers and
sisters unreservedly identify
him as their favorite sibling our
children obviously make our life very
full
while i am a judge i'm better known back
home as a room parent
carpool driver and birthday party
planner
when schools went remote last spring i
tried on another hat
jessie and i became co-principals of the
barrett e-learning academy
and yes the list of enrolled students
was a very long one
our children are my greatest joy even
though they deprive me of any reasonable
amount of sleep
i couldn't manage this very full life
without the unwavering support of my
husband jesse
at the start of our marriage i imagine
that we would run our household as
partners
as it has turned out jesse does far more
than his share of the work
to my chagrin i learned at dinner
recently that my children consider him
to be the better cook
for 21 years jesse has asked me every
single morning
what he can do for me and though i
almost always say
nothing he still finds ways to take
things
off my plate and that's not because he
has a lot of free time
he has a busy law practice it's because
he is a superb
and generous husband and i am very
fortunate
jesse
[Applause]
jesse and i have a life full of
relationships
not only with our children but with
siblings
friends and fearless babysitters one of
whom is with us today
i am particularly grateful to my parents
mike and linda coney i spent the bulk
of i have spent the bulk of my adulthood
as a midwesterner
but i grew up in their new orleans home
and as my brother and sisters can also
attest
mom and dad's generosity extends not
only to us
but to more people than any of us could
count
they are an inspiration
it is important at a moment like this to
acknowledge
family and friends but this evening i
also want to acknowledge you
my fellow americans the president has
nominated me
to serve on the united states supreme
court
and that institution belongs to all of
us
if confirmed i would not assume that
role for the sake
of those in my own circle and certainly
not for my own sake
i would assume this role to serve you
i would discharge the judicial oath
which requires me to administer justice
without respect to persons
do equal right to the poor and rich
and faithfully and impartially discharge
my duties under the united states
constitution
i have no illusions that the road ahead
of me will be easy
either for the short term or the long
haul
i never imagined that i would find
myself in this position
but now that i am i assure you that i
will meet the challenge
with both humility and courage
members of the united states senate i
look forward to working with you during
the confirmation process
and i will do my very best to
demonstrate that i am worthy of your
support
thank you